don't come guys before the video starts
miss do check out it's a brilliant app
for those who want to pray Salah and
share their wards check them out now
sorry I just want to ask you a question
are you a butcher the butcher yeah okay
do you know how to cut me okay all right
calm down oh just ask him let's ask the
big question how you doing probably okay
yeah good you know I always come here I
really like the food I have some doubts
I don't know if you cook my food but how
long have you been a chef for 12 years
okay that's interesting you know how to
cut it you sure okay once do I did ask
you a question do not change fire
now be new women do you know question
okay how long how long have you been
doing this
drag cleaning for all you know I want to
know cause I want to know do you guys do
you know how to wash clothes how long
how long but like a million for one year
two years how long this year at 50 or 60
years make feet thick vida Allahu Akbar
yeah
subhanAllah I bring all my clothes baba
inshallah one day yeah may Allah bless
you we go to Nando's anyhow he loved a
lot of motion
[Music]
we went in to come in and tell people
get offended when you ask them questions
okay guys let's stop here for a second
what is the whole purpose of this video
hmm well let me explain we went to
different people in different
professions and asked them basic simple
abc123 kind of style questions and most
of them got offended now when we ask a
ex-muslim who's been in the religion
yeah apparently for a good couple years
etc I'm sure surely they would know the
five pillars of Islam are the six
pillars of a mile the basic surah fatiha
come on right let us find out right now
with these case studies here we go enjoy
it okay you say we worship the Kaaba
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
understand we fun I didn't even ask you
I just said I could have em you just
said what is that man so then pizza with
all due respect there as a Bravo - Bravo
your heart to heart yeah if you don't
know the facts here how can i I can
assume the best to see you know what
pizza you came to this time you never
understood it and you left something you
never understood the party is the basic
of the basis of of the basic of the
basics of the yeah anyone who claims to
be a cop was that muscle that's fit yeah
so guys before we go to the reminder
ensure I just want to say thank you to
our sponsor Mequon inshallah whoever
Sadie's a food garage we do servicing
MOT bodywork and what we carry out
servicing on your car your warranty is
not effective and your break now is not
effected and we update the service or
the Mercedes system doctor so the only
way you're affected is in a good way
okay guys so that was a little
experiment that we did in sha la to just
highlight the importance of what we're
discussing today
so you can see for yourself brother and
sisters when we go to people who have
spent vast amount majority of their life
will even be it one year two years
whatever it may be they have a basic
basic understanding of the basics basic
tenants of that specific profession but
one thing that you will see is that with
a lot of its Muslims I'll call them the
ex-muslims yeah okay with the IIx you
know they're kind of special people that
they claim this and you see it's like a
trend it's like a fashion yeah and
obviously it's a fashion and a trend and
everyone's claiming it because you know
there's a consistency and you know it's
because they genuinely mean what they
say and it's got nothing to do with no
yes anyways I'm sure you get what I'm
talking about and you see with this
specific individual and many of them you
had one who left this lamp because he
couldn't get into her own relationship
and because he wanted to buy a house and
rebar you know it's so hard you know to
me you know buying a house is more
important so I always thought me so hard
so anyways all that kind of stuff Roman
sisters and we asked this specific
and as I showed you guys the basics we
asked them the six pillars of Eman yeah
let's only asked him I did not expect
him to reply to me and say a man will be
lucky women like riccati were cool to me
here also they were when the omen acid
were other Hyder he was Shari nobody
asked you to repeat that in Arabic to me
nobody told you to say that
all I said was what is the six pillars
of Islam and I did that instantly as he
was messaging because usually they tend
to with our other Christian so-called ex
Muslim who went to Google and copy and
paste it and absolutely embarrassed
himself and humiliated himself and this
is keep happening upon humiliation and
humiliation you know now Allah says in
the Quran that those who are blinded you
know their hearts are closed it's like
layers and layers of darkness but when
they put their hand out to reach like
they put their hand out they will not
even be able to see the hand and you can
see embarrassing situation and Brahma
Farid that absolutely humiliated and
destroyed this specific person as well
so what I wanted to say was this promise
sisters Allah says in the Quran in surah
maidah verse 54 o you who believed
whoever of you should revert from his
religion Allah will bring forth in place
of them a people he would love and who
would love him and are humbled towards
the believers and power again powerful
against the disbelievers and that my
special friend is watching this it's
obviously going to thinking ah you see
powerful against the disbelievers harsh
towards this believers which kind of
disbelievers their enemies 100% yes so
they strive in the course of Allah and
do not fear the blame of a critic this
is the favor of Allah he bestows it upon
whom He wills and Allah is
all-encompassing and knowing
so as you can see brother and sisters
once again over and over again that this
is nothing but a fashion a trend where
there's money to be made and Islam puts
breakfast on their table everything this
guy these people do here the clothes
that they buy the food that they eat the
schools that they send their kids to
whatever they do it is Islam that is
putting that on their table and that is
what they do they do not attack any
other religion you see a common trait
any other religion and another tree that
you see with these ex-muslims is that
they will never talk about 1 million
people dying in Iraq they will never
talk about far
many people being killed massacred in
Afghanistan they will never talk about
Burma they will never talk about
Palestine these hypocrites these
absolute hypocrites they would never
talk about you know be a Christchurch
etc yeah and then we call these little
nonsense oh no I didn't talk about
Christchurch please yeah you can see
very clearly they do not care they do
not care and this is one trait that you
will see without a shadow of a doubt
they never talk about the oppression
that the Muslims go through you see very
clearly with us we are against all kind
of oppression against done towards
anybody and this is why I wanted to do
this video from sisters to show you guys
inshallah how allah subhanho wa taala
exposes these people yeah and this same
very guy i asked him to come to the UK
and whatever debate monsters excuses
they don't want to come before there was
a abdullah guy yeah as you can see
brother and sisters what lie just to
keep it simple short to the point Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala is not in need of them
he may get replaced like his happy days
they leave Allah doesn't need you my my
friend Allah doesn't need you and
hundred love we expose you and we will
carry on exposing people like yourselves
inshallah so inshallah brothers and
sisters we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
to keep us firm on his religion
inshallah always make to our do not be
among those who are arrogant yeah they
think they are saved
yeah they don't need nothing else no we
humble ourself me myself you know myself
I myself need to see her on a daily
basis every single one of us do not
forget that Allah
found you lost and guided you so thank a
lot some animals on a day and night for
what you have because a lot of people
are going astray inshallah why because
God knows whims and desires few a few
things they might go through like
everybody else does
and the disturber we ask Allah
subhanAllah Allah to bring them back to
Islam inshallah and those who are
struggling and going through issues
doubts Salam is here for you guys once
it's done one of the reasons we serve
Salam to answer these doubts inshallah
you can get in contact me personally I
can come and visit you personally
inshallah and we can ensure I help you
to rebuild your Iman and then those
those dubs
and turn a new page towards your mind
shown above ancestors
thank you for watching this video please
share with your friends and family
insha'Allah and to the lady at Nando's
please forgive me I just genuinely
wanted to know if you can cook chicken
which I think you did say you can but
you know hope you get the point
inshallah Barack Lafitte may Allah bless
you guys may Allah grant you guys Jannah
assalamo alaikom what am i try better
care to - next time goodbye